because she's still my wife it ain't no
it ain't no paperwork i love that i love
it i love that kanye west just made it
crystal clear he wants kim kardashian
back i always believe and trust in him
that he will
always eventually explain himself
because i know his heart on thursday the
grammy winner appeared on revolts
podcast drink champs marking the
rapper's first big interview since the
release of donda his long-awaited 10th
studio album that dropped back in august
he's done miracles
and during the chat kanye got candid
about his split from kim after six years
of marriage snl making my wife say i
divorced him on tv because they just
wanted to get that bar off and i ain't
never even seen the papers we're not
even divorced
so how we
cause that ain't no joke to me of course
kim filed for divorce back in february
and when the kkw beauty founder hosted
saturday night live last month she
addressed their breakup during her
opening monologue when i divorced him
you have to know it came down to just
one thing
his personality
i know that sounds mean but people keep
telling me that comedy comes from truth
and if there's one thing that i always
strive to be it's genuine now kanye says
he wants to get back together
my kids want their parents to stay
together i want their parents i want us
to be together but if you try to be
together too if you look at the media
that's not what they promoting that's
not what they want they want it to be a
new wedding a new episode a new tv show
and then they have people all around and
my wife here you know this is publicist
that's next to her i don't [ __ ] with her
and just in case that whole message
wasn't clear he doubled down on it i
want to pull my family back together i'm
assuming this interview is not that
helpful to that that's my family hulu of
course after 20 seasons on e the
kardashian jenner family is now gearing
up for their new reality series on hulu
which explains kanye's reference to the
streaming service i'm just extremely
happy can you tell by my face
last month kim's sister khloe kardashian
stopped by the ellen degeneres show and
revealed the show is dropping in early
2022. yeah i think in a few months
either end of january
early february fast really fast so
that's the beauty of hulu we're
streaming and we get to have a much
quicker turnaround than previously and
we're really excited they're here now in
the back shooting with us and we're so
happy to be you know up and rolling
again as for kim a source previously
told et she had dinner with pete
davidson in staten island on tuesday
night
i mean i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
the dinner date marks the second
sighting for the 41 year old reality
star and the 27 year old comedian after
they were first snapped holding hands on
a roller coaster at not scary farm in
buena park california it was calming the
source explained quote pete and kim have
been enjoying their time together and
are having fun both are recently single
and have bonded over that meanwhile a
second source told et it's a little more
than that quote kim and pete like each
other they are trying to play it off
that they are just friends but it's a
little more than that right now they're
having a lot of fun together pete makes
kim laugh and makes her feel special
pete is obviously thrilled and has a
major crush on kim
you